الثقافه تترجم بعده لغات ولغه الطعام هي
الاغنى والالذ للشعوب العالم دليل الاطعمه
والمشروبات والاطباق التقليديات تيست اطلس
اصدر قيمته السنويه لافضل المطابخ حول
العالم لعام 2022 القائمه الشهيه لمطابخ
العالم اثارت جدلا واسعا واستقبلت
بانتقادات اللاذعه عبر تويتر وانستغرام
تسالها المتابعون كيف ياتي المطبخ
الامريكي في المركز الثامن بينما مثلا
المطبخ المغربي في المركز الرابع و90 وقبل
الاخير في القائمه
المستخدمون معترضون ايضا بسبب ان نحو نصف
القائمه من المطابخ الاوروبيه ربما الشيء
الوحيد الذي اتفقوا عليه هو ان المطبخ
الايطالي يستحق ان يكون في الصداره كما
جاء في ذلك للعام عربيا المطبخ الجزائري
في المركز الرابع والثلاثين سوريا في
المركز السابع والثلاثين بينما المطبخ
اللبناني بالمرتبه الاربعين والتونسي في
المرتبه الثامنه ولا ابراهيم والذي
تشاركنا اسراره الزميل احلام العبدلي من
تونس
[موسيقى]
المطبخ التونسيه هو جزء من المطبخ
المغربيات واليهوديه ومن ثم العربيه
والتركيه والايطاليه وثقافه اخرى
[موسيقى]
يعرف المطبخ التونسي بترائه بالنشويات
والفواكه والخضروات لحم الذقن هو المفضل
مع استعمال المكثف للدجاج يشتهر ببهاراته
الفريده والمكونات الطازجه التي تدخل في
اعدادي لائحه حافله من الاطباق التي تتاثر
بالمواسم كغيرها من اطباق المتوسط
[موسيقى]
الخبز العنصر الرئيسي في المطبخ التونسي
وتختلف وطرق عمله وتقديمه الثوم وزيت
الزيتون مكونات قلم تغيب عن وجبه اطبق
الاسماك وغلل البحر هي عباره عن حفل بحر
مصغر يزين المواد في كل فصل
القهوه والشايب شعبيه كبيره في تونس قائمه
طويله من الحلويات التقليديه اللذيذه
والمتنوعه وهي رمز قار في الاحتفالات
والاعياد مطبخ لا يستغني عن الشمس
باختصار المطبخ التونسي حاله خاصه غير
ممسوح بها لاحباء الرشاقه والحميه الى
صباح العربيه احلام العبد اللي تونس
السوري والترجي واللبناني اقعدي اطيب مطبخ
بعد الاكل اللبناني الاكل اللبناني بصراحه
كل اكلكم يجنن شو اقول لك يعني بالله تحكي
عن المشويات ولا التبوله ولا الحمص مطبخ
الفلسطيني في المسخن وفي المقلوبه الابط
ال
المنسف المطبخ المغربي
ايه الاكل متعه يعني اي طبقه كان في اي
بلد ف كل بلد تشتهر فيه طبيعي بس خلينا
نشرح للمشاهدين تيست اطلس للتصنيف هو
انطلق في 2015 كانت مبادره من صحفي
كرواتيا للمفارقه لكن الان لحظه باهتمام
عالمي وتجذب قائمه الكثير من الانتقادات
طبعا كل عام وكيما قلت نادين هذا العام لا
احد تقريبا حتى من مواطنين الدول التي
ذكرت مطابخها في القائمه لا احد رضي عن
التصنيفته اه يعني مثلا اذا بدنا نحكي عن
هولنديين بولنديين كمان تعجبوا انه
مطابخهم في المركز الخمسين الاولى هم
نفسهم متفاجئين الملف هذا هذه السنه انه
الدليل الشخصيه نهتم بالرد من جهاته قال
دائما هناك اشخاص غاضبه في نهايه كل عام
مع نشر هذه القائمه همم تيس اطلس حتى انهم
يستقبلوا المكالمات من سفارات سفارات دول
تستفسر عن معايير ترتيب الدول كلها
كمان الدليل او بانه كيف منهجيه بتعتمد
اولا انه تقييم المستخدمين للاطعمه في في
قاعده موجوده هاي قاعده خاصه للبيانات لهم
وكمان اكدوا اكثر من مره على النزاهه لا
يحتسبون الاصوات التي يتضح انها ربما تعطي
تقيمات منخفضه لجيرانهم او درجات عاليه
لمطابخ ولدانهم وفي نهايه السنه هم
بيحسبوا المتوسطه التقييمات وبصروا هذه
القائمه النهائيه بشكل عام الدليل ايضا
قال انه المطبخ الامريكي اللي تحدثنا عنه
ينادين جاء ثامنا فعلا اثار الغضب
والسوريه والسخريه ليس فقط دونات وبرجر يا
نادين او مشروبات غازيه يعني ما هو مطبخ
يعني جدا بحسب ما يقول ذلك يعني انت عم
تحكي عن اكثر من خمس سنوات
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من دبي الزميله المزاري مراسل
صباح العربيه
المطعم الايطالي تصدر قائمه تست اطلس ماذا
تقول عنه اين انت موجود تحديدا
مغشش الناس
يعني انا صباح الخير لكم
بالايطالي انا برفقه الشيف ايلاريا
الايطاليه للحديث عن المطبخ الايطالي الذي
يقدم الذ الوجبات طبعا برايك كثيرين والذي
يتصدر قائما افضل المطابخ لعام 2022 نحنا
بشيك نونه همم
بدي اسالها اول سؤال يا سهام ونادين ليش
المطبخ الايطالي
ههه
اقول ابرز خمس اطباق بالنسبه لايطاليا
المشهورين حول العالم
اكيد سباجيتي الايطالي
اكيد البيتزا الايطاليه
على فكره البيتزا نابوليتاني
نابولي بتكون ها هاي اجتني الفيزا بالوقت
المناسبه تامر المعنى المصور ناصر
الانتباه يمينك
شو هالريح يا جماعه
وفي عندهم طبعا الحلويات الايطاليه
استنى انه تخلص حكي
مش مشكله ابدا
الاطباق الحلو فيها انه بتكون بكل بلد
الهايتها
الي صار هلا هل تعلمون يا سهام ونادين انه
ثاني طبق بفرنسا شو تحذروا غير انه همم
الفرنسيه ثاني طبق الكباب الذي يؤكل في
فرنسا ليه لانه تعودوا عليه جاء من ثقافه
ثانيه جاء من والله العظيم جاء من فيوجن
اجا من بلاد خلطه المكونات وصار هذا الطبق
نمبر 2 بفرنسا يعني انا برده في شغله مع
احترامنا لاصدقائنا اللبنانيه المطاعم
اللبنانيه اخذت صيد في فرنسا
اجوا من سوريا
صار برده يحط الكوزينه لانه الاوروبي تعود
انه كويزين للبنات او المطبخ اللبناني
فصار انه قصيت للمطبخ اللبناني بغض النظر
اذا كان الشف هو سوري او من منطقه اخرى من
الوطن العربي او من المتوسط منطقه حوض
المتوسط وكذلك شفنا ها الشيء بالياباني
كثير في مطاعم يابانيه انا شفتها بالعالم
ما بكونوا ياباني بس لانه
المطبخ الياباني صاروا يقصدوا هذه المطاعم
اساس انه هو مطعم ياباني
هل من خلال سفره وترحالك في معظم بلاد هذا
العالم لاحظت انه مطبخ العربي في انه همم
هويه عالميه الناس بتعرفه
نعم مش بس العربي اذكر تماما اطيب مطعم
افغاني اكلت اكل افغاني كان في بوستن في
مستشفى في امريكا فيعني صار انه المطابخ
لا لها علاقه بس انه الواحد الشخص من هذيك
البلد صاروا يتقنه انا بذكر تماما بديغيتس
وحده بتعمل كسكس الكسكس المغربي كانت
صينيه الشاف فهلا صاروا الشيف مثل ما صغر
العالم صغر المطبخ صار انه كلهم يتعلموا
من بعض ويقدمه اطباق مختلفه من من ثقافات
مختلفه في نفس المطبخ يعني هي موجوده في
مطعم ايطالي اكيد
في دبي ولكن هي ممكن تكون بتعمل اطباق
خليني اسالها
كويسين ار يو ار يو
يوتيوب
في الاكل الايطالي قالت كمان انا بطبخ اكل
اسباني فهذا الي بيحكي عنه على كل حال بدي
اتلككم لانه حان وقت الافطار الغداء مع
الشيف
والبيتزا جاهزه ونهاركم سعيد